A stitch pattern in the CB1 box is only
a design made up of black
and white squares.
To create color work, slip, tuck,
or knit any automatic stitch pattern
technique, you first need
to instruct the machine.
This tutorial will cover how to tell
the CB1 box which knitting carriage you're
using and how to instruct it to position
the stitch pattern on the needle bed.
From the main menu,
we'll choose the positioning program icon,
then choose the pattern positioning icon.
We'll choose which carriage we're going
to be using, either the K carriage,
the Lace carriage, or the G
carriage with the icons.
Then we can choose the pattern range,
either a single motif
or repeat the pattern.
Next, we'll enter in the stitch world
pattern number or the 900 number series,
901 through 999, if you created
your own stitch pattern.
Now, by default, the stitch pattern is
automatically centered on the needle bed.
If you want to shift the stitch pattern
one way or the other,
enter in the number of needles,
left or right, that you want to shift.
Your stitch pattern is now positioned
and you're ready to start knitting.
Now, if this indicator displays a stitch
variation is currently active,
use the Variations menu to select or
deselect stitch variations as needed.
We'll talk more about
this in another video.